man this show is crazy
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings today we're joined by
olivia rodrigo
she's a singer songwriter whose double
platinum debut single driver's license
broke
all kinds of records including spotify's
most stream song in a week
ever she followed that up with her
critically acclaimed no skips album sour
which likewise shot to the top of the
billboard charts
it's been olivia rodrigo's year but how
does she handle the spiciest wings on
the planet
that's the real question we'll find out
today olivia rodrigo welcome to the show
hi
i'm so nervous um but so excited
i was just telling you off camera that
um i've watched so many episodes in
preparation
um but very stoked to be here thank you
for having me what is going through your
head right now like are you a fan of hot
sauce
not at all which is why it's gonna be
interesting to see
how i act um i am the worst with spice
like literally
i like think that bell peppers are spicy
and like don't eat bell pepper so like
that's gonna be fun
[Applause]
[Music]
the handle okay i'm just in the car
oh i'm about at all
so in the intro i mentioned how you're
smashing all kinds of records and i'm
sure that you've long felt that there's
something special about the music but
even you have to be surprised by how
quick
and how big everything's blown up are
you aware of this driver's license
extended cinematic universe whereby
fans will remix the song from the
perspective of like that blonde girl or
the physical driver's license itself
yeah that was actually super cool um
to like watch everyone like create stuff
with the song that i created
and people were like so fun with it like
there was one like from the perspective
of the road and like stuff like that
well i love songwriters and it's always
like really cool to see people
write songs to like something that i had
made it was really cool
and then what's the origin story of the
cover art because that likewise has been
reimagined a million different ways
online
yeah we were at another shoot and i like
knew that the album was going to be
called sour
and one of my makeup artist was like
let's just like put it on your tongue
like let's just like cut out the letters
and like put on your tongue i was like
that's really cool and so when
it came time to do the actual shoot we
like put sour on my tongue and put a
bunch of stickers on my face which i
thought was cool
and i was so like pissed off in the
photo and there was like these like
happy stickers on me and i thought it
was like a cool like metaphor or
something like that but yeah
it's been cool to see people recreate
that too
[Music]
okay wait do it together
cheers cheers
[Music]
good so far
so i understand that your overnight
success story wasn't so overnight at all
actually taking singing lessons at five
years old and then not long after doing
singing showcases and performing at
grocery store openings nearly every
weekend
do you remember the first ever local
talent show that you won like can you
paint the picture for us
oh my gosh yeah i do remember it was
called
it was like for like the boys and girls
club and it was like a boys and girls
club like idol or something
and i was so stoked and they gave me a
trophy that was like as tall as me
at the end and they like gave me like a
big like check with like it was like
a hundred dollars or something but like
at eight years old i was like oh my god
i'm rich i can buy an american girl doll
i've like always been singing and making
music since i could literally talk
and i've been writing songs since i was
like nine years old it's so funny to
like
watch old videos of me back i was like
so like confidence like go up there and
like own it i'd like
wish that i was still like that nowadays
but it's a little more difficult when
you're older
it's good a little bit of a step up yeah
it's okay though i'm okay i'm definitely
a higher temperature than i was before
i sat down at this table but i'm all
right that's the that's the slow roasted
nature of hot ones
slow roasted i love that
so it's clear from watching your music
videos that there's a certain
sentimental
chord that you can hit for example
mixing in
vhs effects or cult classic horror movie
references and a song like good for you
how do you think about blending in
novelty and nostalgia in your art
oh my gosh it's a thoughtful question i
i've always been like such a visual
artist like every time i hear like a
song of mine i
can like instantly like sort of picture
um like
what it looks like and i don't know
maybe that's like my style of
songwriting too but
yeah i'm really inspired by vintage
things and i'm obsessed with the 90s and
90s music and 90s pop culture and so
there's definitely nods to that um
in my music but also like i was born in
2003 it's very much a gen z sort of
thing
so um i mean that like inevitably shows
itself and everything i do speaking of
the good for you video i know that scene
where you're in a
in a bedroom that's filling up with
water there's no cgi involved the
curtains behind you are actually on fire
oh yeah is that something that you can
do multiple takes or is that the kind of
scene like you really have only just one
shot we really like had one shot
um that was so much fun that they
literally like built a room
like flooded it and then like set [ __ ]
on fire was
so cool and like my poor manager was
like so worried the whole time she's
like oh my god don't burn to death but
it was so much fun
it was always fun to do practical
effects and that music video was just so
much fun we shot the entire thing in a
day
just like running on adrenaline so yeah
it was a good experience
all right speaking of running on
adrenaline are you ready to move on here
to the next hot sauce
yeah i'm actually surprised i thought
i'd be dying by now i know we have like
a long way to go
this one just enjoy this all right as
long as you can oh god
don't be used to it girl
[Music]
not bad i feel good i was so nervous
i'm probably gonna die like come like
here but
but right now so far doing laps around
any expectation you had for yourself so
far yeah
i really thought i was gonna die after
the first one i am so bad with spice
so i've spoken to comedians in the past
right when they have something in their
head that makes them laugh they think
about
where does this joke work best you know
does it work best in my stand-up
material does it work best
in a tv sketch does it work best in a
pilot i'm curious as a musician who
covers such a wide gamut of styles
how do you know when a feeling or an
idea will fit best in like
a pop punk song versus like a heartbreak
ballad versus like
an alt rock anthem i feel like sometimes
it always
it doesn't always have to like be so
linear like some of my favorite music is
music that's like
super upbeat but like the lyrics are
like so [ __ ] depressing
i don't know i think that's the cool
thing about making music in 2021 is
everything is becoming increasingly
genreless and you can just like do
whatever you want
i'm always like very like lyric centered
person to like answer your question and
um anytime i'm like coming up with an
idea like a comedian would i just always
like write it down on my phone
and every single song that i've ever
made is usually like started
from that place in an interview with
rolling stone you talk about how much
you don't like
vocal chops what are some other tropes
and pop music that you actively try to
steer clear from
oh that's really difficult because i
love everything i would be like oh i
don't like like down the middle
pop but i like love down the middle pop
so i don't know what it is
um i don't know i am like a big musical
theater lover
and i make my songs like so dramatic
sometimes my producer has to be like
really then olivia reel it in
it's actually good it's like delicious
you're single-handedly like expanding my
taste
all right olivia we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
gram we're doing deep dive on our guests
instagram pull
interesting pictures that need more
contacts so we'll pull up the picture on
the monitor
you just tell us the bigger story can
you give us two highlights
and one low light from your first trip
to london oh
okay um first of all that outfit which i
really love that's definitely a
highlight i like
probably wore that outfit two days in a
row because i was like like nobody say
that i'm wearing it the second day but i
just have to wear it again because i
didn't get pictures in it the first day
um second highlight obviously is i
performed with brits which is my first
performance ever
i sang driver's license and that was so
much fun and
low light i'm not sure if i'm supposed
to say this but
we were quarantining in this little um
like like a like a real like 18th
century english cottage in the
countryside
and it was so cold and we couldn't
figure out how to turn on
like the central air and heating um but
they had a fireplace and so we like
like lit the fireplace all the time and
that's how we kept warm and i just
remember like one day waking up and it
was so
smoky and i think i got like mild carbon
monoxide poisoning because with the
whole day i couldn't stop like throwing
up
in our like english countryside house so
it's
definitely a low light um i recovered i
don't know if i had carbon monoxide
poisoning but i was very sick for a day
but it worked out at the end i had fun
made it through all right up next
you called the deja vu video one of your
favorite things you've ever done what is
this project in particular why is it on
such a pedestal for you
and what story does it tell it has kind
of a killing e vibe to it yes
i'm so glad you said that that is um
that was like literally the reference
i remember them coming up to me like
what do you want to do like you can
literally do anything
you want to do with this song that you
wrote and that was just like so freeing
and exciting for me and
it definitely was like a killing eve
type theme i didn't want to like
hit the nail on the head um of what the
song was talking about i didn't want to
be like so literal and specific so we
thought it would be cool to
um sort of like portray a story of like
two girls who are like obsessed with
each other
because i feel like i don't know
feminine adoration is like something
that
i and lots of my friends feel very
intensely and don't really talk about
super often so
that was the theme of it plus you got to
smash up all those tvs oh yeah
it was so fun it was great
[Music]
okay
a little more heavy uh-huh
it's definitely clearing out my sinuses
a little bit i can like breathe easy
so it's clear that you and dan nigro
really went into the lab with a real
vision for sauer
thinking back on all the creative
decisions is there one that you're proud
that you defended on behalf of the album
um yeah um the first thing that comes to
mind
is um deja vu actually uh
the post course was initially going to
be vocal chops which we talked about
before which i hate for whatever reason
and everyone was like the vocal shop
sound amazing it's like so cool and like
trendy and all this i was like i
literally would rather die than put
vocal chops in my song
um no shade to anyone who does that's
just not my thing um
and uh so i wanted to put that like
really cool um
like chunky crunchy synth sound in there
it sounds like an electric guitar but
it's actually a synth
and i had to fight sort of hard to get
that on the record but it happened and
i'm really glad that it happened that
way
and i'm sure like at this point you know
the team's starting to fill up and you
have a lot of people that are like
you know do this or that or say this or
that or wear this or where that what's
something that you find yourself pushing
back on
i don't know i guess the thing i push
back on sometimes is like sometimes i'm
just like
yo i like need a break like i can't
write anything anymore like i'm
completely tapped
so i mean that's the only thing i'll
ever like i don't know push back on i
suppose
you and me both you know this this show
has just been going like pretty much
hitting every thursday for like the last
six years
and so you're tasteful to handle it well
i just i think about what it was like
back in the day to have like a normal
job and i'm like well
if this is the thing that i have to do
to not go back because i can't go back i
can never go back
then i'll just deal with it but you know
sometimes i'm like hey you know between
seasons maybe we can take more than
three weeks off right
yeah go on vacation go on go on an
expensive vacation with the hot ones
money
i'm excited for it i'm saying all right
are you ready to move on here to the
next wing
love burns hotter than l this is perfect
okay oh god i'm feeling it
[Music]
it's really delicious though it's like
it's a great vegan wing
what insight do you have on putting
together a kick-ass bridge because you
do really
seem to nail those kinds of moments yeah
um i think the coolest thing about a
brit oh my god this is uh
i think the coolest thing about a bridge
is like i'm talking about something that
you didn't talk about in the rest of the
song it's like
providing like another like opinion or
like another
perspective or something on the song
everyone's laughing at me i
i'm a super dynamic songwriter i love
songs that are like really quiet and
then get really big and like stuff like
that so i always
either try to have like a like a like a
down bridge where it gets like really
quiet and
introspective or like a really like big
one um i don't know bridge is just
something like different because i like
my songs to be just like all over the
place
off of hope you're okay what does it
mean to address the letters to the holes
in my butterfly wings it's very poetic
i have no idea i don't know it sounds
cool
i don't know um we wanted to like
have something that's sort of a little
abstract and up for your interpretation
and i love butterflies that's like a
sour theme so
incorporated that in there is there an
olivia rodrigo lyric that comes to mind
when you think about how you're feeling
right now
happy and healthy that's the line
i'm very happy and healthy i'm moving my
best life currently eating hot ones with
you
you say that now because you haven't
tried the next wing yet
oh the bomb oh jesus christ the one with
the like
the nuke on it jesus christ okay
here i go my nose is running
[Music]
hmm
the immediate
okay the the hot ones experience
starting to take form
[Music]
oh okay
so on your birthday last year you
tweeted i'm 17 years old today but i
still do not know the different styles
of eggs only scrambled
now that you're a year older and have
just tried one of the spiciest wings of
all time
i want to hit you with a few different
egg preparation styles
to see if anything's changed over the
last year okay
yeah what style of eggs is this
sunny side up it is sunny side up olivia
you know your ex
all right up next do you know this um
it's a hot i mean like it's not
hard-boiled it's like uh
oh my god
um what is it called
they like have them at tea parties what
is it called deviled eggs
that's opposite yeah those are eggs
benedict but
technically you're right those eggs are
poached
things go things flying off the edge
here we're flying off the edge right off
okay sorry
no no long leash on this show whatever
you got to go through to get through it
when someone asked you your favorite
snack recently you replied trader joe's
oatmeal cookies till the day i die
what's your response to people who think
that an oatmeal raisin cookie can never
ever be better than chocolate chips oh
my god i hate chocolate chip cookies i
don't know what it is i love chocolate
and i love cookies but
chocolate chip i can't even chocolate
chip
cookies are not it for me
everyone makes fun of me because oatmeal
raisin cookies are like grandma you
cookies but
they're the best and i feel like they're
actually like hearty and like somewhat
healthy for you like oatmeal has like
fiber and stuff
let's speak all right
all right up next we have the scorpion
disco how are you feeling how are you
feeling
oh my god it looked oh my god
it like burns your lips
all right now or never okay
oh my god um
so one thing you and i have in common is
asking people that we meet for the first
time if they have any ghost stories and
i imagine that wouldn't be a move of
yours unless of course you had
at least one of your own no i don't i
don't [ __ ] with ghosts and they don't
[ __ ] with me it's like
it's a really great thing that we have
going on um
the one that i do tell is my mom grew up
in wisconsin and her parents like had
this like
nice house that they got really cheap
and one day she woke up to go to the
bathroom
and she saw a man standing at the top of
the stairs
i didn't tell anyone until 25 years
later and my grandma was like oh you
know the reason we got the house were so
cheap is because somebody died in the
basement like a man died in the basement
which
blew my mind i heard that story like 12
years old and i was like oh my god mom
that's crazy
um
don't have any myself and hopefully
never will
i'm crying oh my god
[Music]
man this show is crazy
[Music]
but for somebody who thought a bell
pepper was spicy
you're doing amazing things here today
it's adrenaline
[Music]
all right man cheers last one
cheers
[Music]
whoa okay all right olivia rodrigo
thankfully we've made it to the end of
our spice symphony here today
and just one more hurdle left to go so
to close things out what i want to do
is name a hot sauce and you tell me the
first musical effect that comes to mind
you know
maybe the hot sauce can remind you of a
grunge guitar riff or a big synth or
okay a melotron and we'll just take it
from there does that sound good
uh okay i think you think i'm smarter
than i actually am but i'll try
love burns hotter than um i think of
like a sick like
crunchy like petal guitar riff hell yeah
the bomb beyond insanity
um i think it's some like edm thing like
some cool like pad
scorpion disco something off like i do a
leap of record i don't know
oh no you know what it is it's like a
like one of those like midi like um
violin things that like sounds fake and
then the last dab
the wing that you just ate
piano because because yeah that yeah a
piano thing because piano is my favorite
and that one is my favorite because it's
the last one and we're done
we are done you made it through nothing
else to go for
no more vegan wings you have conquered
the table
olivia rodrigo now there's nothing left
to do but roll out the red carpet for
you
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
hey what's up my name is olivia rodrigo
i just finished
uh hot ones and it was a lot of fun um
i'm never gonna eat a hot wings ever
again in my life
but it was fun uh today um yeah
uh you can listen to my first album
sour everywhere hope you really like it
um you might cry like i did in this
episode of hot ones because it was so
[Music]
spicy
you crushed it oh my god that was so fun
such thoughtful questions
oh thank you oh wow which one was the
worst
oddly the this this one
that's when it you were like yeah that
was when i was like oh shit's getting
real
hey what's going on everybody this is
sean evans checking in with some very
exciting first week feast news
now when i'm not over here choking down
chicken wings on hot ones
i happen to be a huge pizza guy sicilian
neapolitan deep dish dollar slice
frozen pizza i love it all which is why
i'm excited to announce that first we
feast has a brand new show
pizza wars where pizza master nicole
russell takes on contenders in a battle
royale of different pizza styles
i'm on there judging the deep dish
episode naturally but the show has
other great guests as well including
buddies like babish
and frank pinello but that's enough chit
chat let's let the sizzle reel do the
talking
alright roll the tape
[Music]
the misconception is that if you get a
lot it's good
bite for bite this is the best eating
experience i've ever had on one of these
things
my opponents and i will be taking on a
new piece of theme challenge
every episode i wish that i could give
you both trophies but they only gave me
one you guys have an extra
they don't have an extra don't get it
twisted this is a competition and i want
to win
but i'm also here to catch up with a few
of my friends i couldn't have done this
episode with nobody else
learn some new tricks to use at home you
got to slice the garlic thin
so thin that it liquefies in the pan no
no thank you for that
thank you nona i eat a whole bunch of
pizza
oh my god
so get ready people peace awards is
[Music]
coming
you